would you consider having a discussion
with Thomas solo that's Sam Dugan Dugan
Dugan probably yeah I definitely
considered I'm thinking hard about
reaching out to him I I have some
discussions coming up that you might be
interested in so I'm going to talk on
charcoal willings podcast and he was the
leader of the Navy SEALs team in Ramadan
and he's quite the tough character
I met him down in San Diego a while back
a month ago or so and that was very
interesting I have a video already
prepared
that's an interview with ayaan Hirsi Ali
it was done by Skype and needs some
editing and so that's been a bit delayed
I interviewed or discussed I had a
discussion with Nina Paley who's a great
animator you guys should look her up
that's Nina Paley she animated a lot of
the Old Testament and set it to music
and I think her animations are
unbelievably beautiful and the mean she
has great musical taste
they're illegal videos basically she's
making an illegal movie but anyways I
really like your stuff um I also had a
discussion with Claire layman who runs
quill at which is a new news magazine
online which I think has got real
promise and we had a good discussion and
let's see is that it I think that's it
and you probably know or maybe you don't
I just finished a discussion with
Camille Paglia and we went down there I
took a film crew down there to
Philadelphia and met her at her
University and we talked for a couple of
hours and that was really interesting
she's quite the fireball that woman
and unbelievably verbally fluent and
sharp and so I finally met someone who
could talk more than me and and that's
probably good so but I really enjoyed
speaking with her and I think about a
hundred thousand people have watched
that now in a day so that's pretty good
so we talked about post-modernism and
malaise that confronts the modern
University and all of those sorts of
things so Robin Dionne says do you ever
miss Montreal hey I was just in Montreal
I went there to saw saw a band called
Half Moon Run which I bound I would
highly recommend they were playing with
the Montreal Symphony Orchestra and I
got invited to meet one of the singers
and also go in now and see the concert
which was excellent and yeah I'd miss
Montreal Montreal is a great city for
you Americans who are listening should
go visit Montreal man it's a cool place
and spend a week there in the summer
it's it's a really good city in every
way so